dans le ciel de toulouse
ce sont de grands oiseaux maladroits aux
proportions monstrueuses mais ici
personne ne s'étonne plus de la
perpétuelle noria des bélougas
car contrairement à son concurrent
boeing airbus ne comprit pas ses avions
sur un seul site de chester en
grande-bretagne à hambourg ou
saint-nazaire les pièces affluent des
quatre coins de l'europe
jusqu'à cette cathédrale industrielle de
6 hectares où sont assemblés les plus
gros avions de la gamme les a330 et a340
tous les quatre jours commence alors un
gigantesque meccano toutes les parties
d'un appareil sont mises bout à bout le
début d'une véritable course contre la
montre en quatre jours il nous faut
impérativement assez de ce poste à
l'autre et le post précédent doit aussi
travailler en quatre jours donc on a
bien une notion de chaîne un peu comme
chez renault
car airbus met les bouchées doubles pour
faire jeu égal avec son rival américain
il faut neuf cent mille river pour
construire un a340 mais grâce à cette
machine 30 heures suffisent de réaliser
les coutures de l'avion sur la chaîne
tout a été pensé pour moderniser la
production ne s'en compagnon seulement
travaillent pas l'assemblage des plus
gros appareil 200 techniciens très
spécialisés qui teste et re test chacune
des fonctions de l'âge que les pilotes
un tas d'hommes ball
s'il faut piquer la guerre ici pour
redresser l'avion s'il est trop trop bas
et c'est donc s'il ne la remet pas
valide sa me liés
l'obsession et à la sécurité les
circuits sont testées en conditions
réelles 250 kilomètres de fils
électriques parcours la carlingue
si l'un d'eux est coupée la situation
vire au casse-tête chinois des fois des
fois on y passait les jours sur une
table
un peu plus loin ce sont les moteurs que
l'on fait tourner pour la première fois
l'avion disparaît alors dans un nuage de
fumée provoqué par les huiles de
stockage lors de ce point fixe les
techniciens ont une lourde
responsabilité
préparez l'avion pour le premier vol
d'essai ou comment vous étiez jeune vous
vous réveillez votre pilote
oui parce qu'on aime le plus
faire rouler la viande de le voir vivre
ça fait rêver mais c'était conscient
m'amèneront jamais l'avion
ce rôle est réservé aux seigneurs
d'airbus les pilotes d'essai
paradoxalement l'une des phases les plus
longs de la préparation des avions reste
l'aménagement commercial trois semaines
car les intérieurs sont de plus en plus
sophistiqués chaque passager brûle un
film différent et après il ya tous les
réglages électriques du fauteuil ya un
repose-pied électrique
ça me faudrait qu'il fait kiffer push
est tombé en première classe
un confort qui se paie un nom appelé la
commande c'est la livraison de
l'appareil 7,6 millions de francs payés
sans aucun état d'âme suisse avait en
fait en ce sens en fois mieux que sauf
cas qu'il vient d'acheter une nouvelle
voiture
il sort du concessionnaire acheter un
nouvel avion c'est très agréable je vais
dire ça va faire gagner beaucoup
d'argent alors fait compagnie moins de
deux heures plus tard l'avion repart
pour une carrière qui durera plusieurs
décennies